Oh
I believe that I have a very loud voice
and I'm not ashamed or embarrassed or
shying away from expressing what i think
i don't have to like everyone my website
is called perez hilton com it's not
called the New York Times I don't have
to feign objectivity
I love the entertainment industry if I
didn't I wouldn't still be in it and I
wouldn't have chosen that topic for my
website when I first started blogging
when I moved to Los Angeles in 2002 I
wanted to be an actor but like nine out
of ten people that moved to Los Angeles
it didn't work for me and I'm so
thankful because I'm so much happier now
doing what I do then if I would have
been an actor that was struggling to
work or even if I did get some kind of
success I love being my own boss I love
calling the shots and I love what I do I
feel really lucky
my perspective on Fame hasn't changed at
all because I'm still normal and have a
normal person and I do normal things I
haven't let fame affect me which
sometimes people do they can buy into
their own hype I think the fact that I
have an alter ego helps and I think the
fact that for every two people that like
me there's probably 4.5 that hate me
that also helps too so I don't think
that I'm hot you know I don't have
a big head well I already do have a big
head but I don't have as big a head as I
could have